for those interested consider checking
out my books on topics similar to this
video to the links in the description if
you like this video I think you'll
especially enjoy notes from the end of
everything
I realized recently that I'll never know
what I look like all I'll ever see is a
two-dimensional representation of myself
reflected back at me in mirrors and
photos and people
but never the real thing
I'm the closest anyone will ever be to
me and I'll never even know what I'm
really like from the outside
it's not even just how I look I'll never
know how I come off in general how other
people perceive and think of me how I
feel to be around I'll never know for
sure what the sum of my qualities equals
on the other side of the equation
and in a lot of ways I think that's
actually who I am
I went on this trip to try to find
myself but so far I've mostly just
realized the foolishness of this I don't
even know who I'm looking for at this
point
going somewhere to find yourself is kind
of like putting your glasses on to try
to find your glasses you'll never find
them because you already have them on
the pace of this country is much slower
than what I'm used to which probably
isn't great for someone who came here
trying to run from everything maybe it's
more accurate to say that I went on this
trip to try to run or hide from
everything rather than find anything at
all
it's like I've been in a game of hide
and seek with everything and this whole
time I thought I was the one looking but
I've been the one hiding
and everything is really good at always
finding you
some things you can't hide from
I've mostly been going to cafes and bars
people watching
the pace has been good for reflection I
suppose it makes people more observable
I probably passed by more people in the
last two months than I have in my entire
life prior
there's something about being in a
different place where people are
noticeably different from you that
reminds you that people are different
from you
of course this sounds obvious but when
you actually think about the real lives
of random strangers versus just knowing
that they are out there it truly makes
them strange all the people I've walked
by sat next to encountered they all have
their own lives with their own versions
of each moment each day the splip of
life in the indeterminable vastness of
time
and their versions are all just as real
and Vivid and intense and important to
them as mine is to me
the woman I passed by on the way into
the cafe the cashier the child and the
mother sitting opposite of me right now
the old man standing far too close I'm
as much of a vague out-of-focus
background character in a scene they
will forget to them as they are to me
they'll never even know that they made
an appearance in my little notebook
written into a blurb of scattered
thoughts and I'll never know if I made
it into anyone else's
but it won't matter it's never about
anyone else anyway
in truth you're the star of every story
you tell even if it seems to have
nothing to do with you which also means
you're not really the star of anyone
else's story even if it seems to be
about you
but someone says about something says
far more about them than the thing
they're talking about
the world is filled with 8 billion
Theaters 8 billion storytellers
narrating their own story to their own
audience that is themselves
I wonder what things have been said
about me when I'm not around
I think I'm gonna stop talking poorly
about anyone behind their back whom I
claim to like or love moving forward
that way I can at least have a false
hope that they aren't about me
I wonder how many of the people I've
passed by in the last couple months
would be the best person I've ever met
if I met them how good could a
friendship or relationship really fit if
I could try them all on
maybe that would just destroy the point
it's a curse really to be human and to
know that there are infinite
possibilities for how life could go and
that you only get to try just one
most of who we become close with is just
by the random odds of proximity chance
met with desperation and the fear of
being alone
and if you're really really lucky maybe
one of those people is someone you would
choose to keep close if you live forever
and met everyone
maybe forming a couple close connections
with a couple people is the best anyone
can really do
and maybe the more you run around
searching for the exact right people and
the exact right things you end up
accidentally sacrificing what is good
and perhaps good is more than enough
eventually all loose threads unravel
only tying things tightly keeps them
together
but in order to do so you have to commit
to them being stuck in place
[Music]
I read a quote recently that goes
something like you can make more friends
in two months by being interested in
people than you can in two years trying
to get people to be interested in you
most of my life has been spent trying to
construct different versions of myself
so that I appear the best I can in other
people's minds but I've never spent much
time trying to even understand other
people's minds
you can't make people like you you can
only try to understand them and hope
they try to do the same back
connecting with people I suppose means
visiting their theater to watch their
film and then extending the offer back
to them
and trusting that they won't leave a
trail of popcorn and sticky soda on the
floor on their way out God knows I've
left plenty of theaters messier than
when I showed up but so of other people
to mine
people are just messy and sticky
I think I'm going to just try to enjoy
the screenings from now on without
worrying so much about the cleanup
at least until I have to
[Music]